- We want to be very
thoughtful of what we're doing,
because you're only as vulnerable
as the one person you let down.
And, so, I don't think
there's a lot of people
in the game that understand
where the business world is going,
and, boy, what you do for a living,
you know, at the position
that you're doing it at,
like, it's just hardcore.
(electronic music)
Yo, what up vlog.
Location, location, location, location,
just like I'm sitting here right now
in Sydney Australia Airport.
And the way I've been thinking
about business down here,
is whether it's for
modeling or for surfing,
or footy kind of culture,
when you understand the
framework that you're playing in
you have a much better
chance of succeeding.
In this little chat I had
with a first round pick
of New York Mets,
I was really to articulate
to him and his family,
but really him, if you watch it carefully,
even though I'm not
directly addressing him,
that you need to squeeze your moment.
I'm yelling at all of you for
squeezing this Facebook Ads,
Instagram influencers moment,
the way I didn't as much
as I wanted to with Google
back in 2002,
'cause it's a moment in time.
If you're an athlete,
and you're lucky enough to be drafted
in New-York-fucking-City,
you need to fucking work.
And whether you're
drafted in New York, LA,
or San Francisco,
or if it's Dallas, Green Bay, or Detroit,
you need to be smart about
the unique opportunities
within the marketplace.
The framework of this conversation, is,
take advantage of your surroundings.
If you're going to UCLA or USC this year,
take advantage of that environment.
If you're going to Duke or North Carolina,
understand and take advantage of that.
If you're going to travel through Europe,
understand the room you're playing in
and the advantages,
the fruits that you can pick from.
You'll see that in this interview.
Well, thanks for reaching out.
And I've been looking
forward to getting together.
- Yeah, no, I've been very
impressed with what I've seen,
very impressed with what you're doing.
- [Gary] Thank you.
- Sort of seen you growing
from the ground up.
And I just wanted to talk
about the agency game,
and what you feel that,
you guys think is different
for the kids out there.
I wanted to come in
and talk a little bit about social media,
and kind of speak to my
son a little bit about it,
and what you feel about,
how you can help kids with regards to
what agencies are not doing,
or what they are doing.
- So, given the opportunity
that we're all sitting here together,
I'm thrilled to, like,
given you have the most context,
obviously, you have the
most context of your son,
and you've been able to context on me,
what can I bring you the most value of?
Is this a theoretical conversation?
Is there some details underneath?
To be very honest,
as you know, where we sit
with baseball versus football,
and things of that nature,
like, I'm obsessed with the
notion of paying forward.
I think karma is the most
practical thing in the world.
Even your first email caught
my attention from the vibe,
the second, black coffee, all that stuff,
so it's all good vibes,
it's all family.
At the highest levels,
I've been in two businesses my life.
My dad had a liquor store,
so I've been in the
liquor and wine business,
and now I'm in the advertising
Madison Avenue industry.
Along with my dad,
and along with my brother,
we've been able to build
much bigger businesses
quicker than anybody has
in both those spaces,
and they have one common theme,
which was, I think what I'm good at
is like CAT-scanning the industry.
And when I looked at him,
I was like, "Wow.
"This is what they're doing wrong.
I'm gonna do this."
This being probably our
third venture, VaynerSports.
I've never looked at an industry.
And because I'm investor in
Uber, and Facebook, and Twitter,
and all these things,
I look at a lot of businesses,
not just the two I've run.
I've never looked at a
business more broken.
Now, I'm empathic to the agents.
To be very honest, I don't
think it's a great business.
You know, making small percentages,
having nobody really locked up,
you can have a kid for a long time,
you know, you get fired before
the real money comes in.
It's not a great business.
And I think when a business is not great,
it leads to bad behavior.
At the same token,
I don't think AJ and I
are necessarily in it
to become rich,
and, so, that allows us to
be a little more altruistic
and, to be very frank, what
I'm most interested in,
which is to fuck it up a little bit.
I mean, very basically,
agents, they don't care about their kids.
And honestly, I get that.
It's a business.
But that's the vulnerability.
The reason we're being so thoughtful,
and listen,
and this is a real player,
this is a real situation,
and we've had some other
real situations in the NBA,
and things of that nature,
is we want to be very
thoughtful of what we're doing,
because you're only as
vulnerable as the one person
you let down.
And, so, I don't think
there's a lot of people
in the game that understand
where the business world is going,
and, boy, what you do for a living,
you know, at the position
that you're doing it at,
like, it's just hardcore, right?
For me, it's data, right?
When you're the human,
people think they're
going to hall of fame,
as they should,
how the fuck do you think they
got there in the first place?
When you look at the data
of the outcomes of careers,
you know, I'm sure you
guys know better than I do,
you're holding your breath,
you're thinking about this,
you're thinking about that.
It's hardcore.
So, there's some good
advantages in baseball
with guarantee contracts,
is if you can get to that place,
but, for me, the biggest thing is,
you have to strike and squeeze,
when the outcome of like this great thing
has this low of percentages,
you have to squeeze the fuck out of it
while you've got the leverage.
I'm a big Jets fan.
I tell these kids when they're a Jet,
I'm like, "Look, you're in New York City.
Like, I'm meeting with you.
You think I would meet with you
if you're weren't a New York."
If you weren't Number
32 of the New York Jets,
I would never spend, you know,
and these kids don't.
I think of Dexter McDougle,
I think about all these kids.
Like, while you're in,
when you're a draft pick of that team,
like the amount of people
that are ruling the world,
especially in New York,
that are diehard Mets fans,
that really give a shit
right now, and may not,
listen, I'm an old time
baseball card collector,
Brien Taylor was the first pick overall
of the New York Yankees,
and we all cared.
- I remember.
I'm a diehard Yankee fan.
Trust me, it hurts my hard
that got draft picked.
(laughs)
- Did you grow up a Yankee fan?
I love it, I love it.
I get it, I get it, I get it.
But it's still great that
he's here, man it's the best.
But, right?
Brien Taylor, forget
about the contract he got,
which was probably why
we all knew who he was,
'cause it was a big one at the time,
you know, every CEO in this,
the biggest city in the world
call it what it is, cared about...
That's right, and for me
the most important thing
like if I was a part of this
team, an enormous amount.
Now first of all, I think
the other thing that's gonna
allow us to be successful
and the thing you should
be always thinking about
is, does the person
representing you have empathy.
And why I think about empathy
so much in this business
is my strategy would be like hey my man
we need to meet everybody that
gives a shit about the Mets
that matters in New York,
that can put you on,
whether that's advice,
whether that's getting you
business opportunites,
whether that's writing you
a $50,000 check when you're
probably worth $1500 dollars
as a face of a marketing campaign
because they can afford it
and they love the fuckin Mets.
Let's do that.
On the flip side, the reason
I said empathy is if he's like
man I'm just working on this
third pitch, I don't like
being around people, I
don't want to go do this.
I don't want people up in my, look,
you've gotta have empathy.
So I think for us uniquely,
because of the marketing
machine, we definitely
have to be smart and listen
carefully of who says they want that.
Who needs that.
- [AJ] If Derek Morgan is a
vegan and I call a chicken wing
restaurant, I'm not going
to bring that to Derek.
That's not authentic to
him, he won't advertise
anything he won't put into his body.
- And that's why the
agents are vulnerable.
The agents, the CA's,
they've got six moves.
And you've got to fit into their moves.
They're gonna try to get
you a sneaker deal, they're
gonna try to, they've got
six moves and so what we're
trying to do is create a swiss army knife
instead of a hammer.
And then to be very frank, win on the
only thing you can win
on which is, if he quit
tomorrow because he fell
in love with yoga retreats
and that's his calling in life,
be his homie for that too.
And I think that's why we're
going to win ultimately,
because if you're in the
business of the kid for life,
regardless, as long as they're
not a complete piece of
crap and changed on you.
We spend so much time on
okay he's from a small town,
what happens when he hits the big city.
We can afford to not be
in the business of getting
the phone call at two in the morning.
So we don't need to be in
that and we're generally not.
And the other thing is,
you get your heart broken.
I already have, four
seconds in the business
we signed a kid who then
fired us before he went
to the league and I watched
it and I'm heartbroken.
I love him, and so we want
to be very thoughtful.
And so I think the way
we're going to beat it,
but I think the most important
thing for you from afar,
and I haven't done a lot
of homework so I don't
want to bullshit but, squeeze
it while you've got leverage.
Not a lot of human beings
get to be the number one pick
of a team in New York, it's a
real thing, it's really real.
Ya know what's funny?
And let me tell you
something, it's not even like
a young or old, I respect
that, and I don't know
and I'm sure he'll speak for himself,
I didn't understand either.
By the way, you don't
even understand, I bet you
you don't even understand
how lucky even are to be
a human being when the
math is 400 trillion to 1.
How can you?
You're a human being.
It's what you know.
He can't feel what it feels
like to only be able to throw
57 like the way I can feel it.
He just doesn't know what that feels like.
He did that when he was seven right?
The key is empathy,
you're right, he doesn't.
And the same way that all
of us sitting here can't.
You can't.
What you've got, you take
for granted by the nature
of being a human being.
It's all of us around
each other that see it
and so for me it's not about,
I'm empathetic I love it.
I'm even more excited
about the meeting based on
the way it's going but I have
no interest in being like
hey listen to me kid, I fuckin
made, that doesn't work.
The reason why so many kids
resonate with me and why I
have 2 million followers on
instagram, is I went to USC
football team and spoke to
the football team and was like
yo, for 91 percent of you,
this is the greatest year
of your life.
And cause it's true.
It's not cause I'm cool or
cause I came in with swag.
It's cause it's true.
Go look at every fucking
person that was drafted in
the first round of major league
baseball and look at what's
happened.
Lot of good, cause there's a
lot of fucking talent there.
But a lot more bad than
you would think just
cause it's life.
The truth, right?
So for me it's super
compounded because of the local
kid and how big the money is in New York.
If you were the first pick
overall for The Royals,
off the field money is
different than being
a first round pick for the
Mets in New York as a local
kid and all the advantages you have.
That's something you need
to debate and it's hard
because it's a counter-pull
from what question
you should be focused on,
just being a great fuckin...
Like I get it right?
That makes sense.
So finding that right
balance I think is super hard
and a challenge but super
important because it becomes,
I spend a lot of time with
kids that just regret.
And just regret, regret, regret right?
I grew up like a lot of
people, which is like fuck man,
I was real sad around third or
fourth grade when I realized
it wasn't gonna happen, ya know?
We all grow up wanting to do what you do
but now that I'm a 41
year old man and now that
entrepreneurship is so cool
it's even easier to say
fuck, thank God I wasn't an athlete.
It's over when you're 30,
ya know for a lot of them.
I think about running Curtis
Martin, ya know running backs
at 28 years old running
back, your finished?
I mean what the fuck, you're a kid right?
We've lived it right?
We've been 28, so I think
it's just all those feelings,
all those thoughts and
I think it's the balance
of following your
intuition and your gut even
when you're so lucky to
have good voices around you
pulling super hard on like
doing what you want to do
and believing and that's real.
In parallel, in opposite
direction of listening
to everything and filtering it.
Not saying no to anything
upfront just so you hear it,
and then you being the filter.
Too many kids just say no upfront
cause it's from their Dad,
it's from somebody else and
it's like fuck you I'm not
gonna be like you I'm gonna
fuckin make, all that shit.
So many people just don't even hear it.
The key, the only piece
of advice is hear it
and then make your decisions.
Not for anybody but yourself,
not for that man, not for her,
not for nobody, for you.
That's how you win, that's
how there's no resentment,
that's how it's real
family all the way through.
I think people break on both parts,
they don't hear every, they
don't listen to everything.
You should listen to
everything and they do make
decisions for other
people besides themselves,
and those two macro
vulnerabilities to me are,
is really my anchor advice
and squeeze the shit
out of your situation
cause it's an opportunity.
- I had a conversation with
his agent, I told his agent
this, and I told him to watch you.
I said you guys got to get
this because if you don't
the industry's gonna go this
way, I just have that feeling
about what you're doing.
And I look at his
opportunities in this city,
who he is, and he has the
same feeling that you have
with your success and where
you're going, he's the same way.
- And you know what's crazy for me?
Unless I have a terminal
disease, I should be good.
He doesn't.
I've become real empathetic to that.
I literally sleep every
night and hope I don't die,
hope I'm not sick, hope
nobody I care about is sick
cause that's my only kryptonite.
Especially now, it's over
other than something tragic
right to the seven people
I give a fuck about
which will slow me down for a year or me,
which would slow me down completely.
You could throw one pitch,
and that's scary as fuck man.
I don't envy, and I
respect the shit out of
the psychology of that which
then creates even a greater
sense of urgency for me
of like hey be thoughtful
of how you want to do this.
At the same token, putting
your face out, putting
yourself out there and doing things.
That's a DNA thing, not
everybody's an extrovert.
Not everybody likes it, not
everybody wants to sellout.
- I don't want to go on
stage or anything like that
so DNA matters too.
- And when you force kids, so
I think it's being thoughtful.
My big thing is reverse engineering.
Dissect the shit, if we
started a baseball division
and he was first, dissect
the shit, have real talk.
Be like, I don't want you
to do shit, I just want
to deliver them what you want me to do.
And if you want to get a
deal with Kit the brand
versus this or if you want
to fuckin, you tell me.
You want to do a deal with
Bape cause you think it's
cool great, let's reverse
engineer it and if you don't,
if it's just money and you
don't give a shit about
which bottled water, it's just money,
which I have empathy for,
I would do that with things
that I don't care about,
that I'm not against.
You may not drink alcohol and
there's rules and all that.
You may not drink bottled
water and you don't
want to do it cause that's
how you roll, mazel tov.
Just figuring it out and
reverse engineering and
creating avenues.
- I think that's something
that him and we were
down by Bape and down
by Kit and these guys
support Jordan to the nth degree.
Its, ya know is he in position now to make
those kind of deals.
- He's in position now to
make those kind of deals
with the people that become
Bape before they're Bape.
- I think he is, I think
if you're a New York, again
I'm making way too many
assumptions just on
the clothes he's wearing and the vibe.
Yes, I think there are
deals, we've already quickly
made a name for ourselves
for getting dollars
in places that people
don't think they are.
Whether off of my equity or just being
strategically smart.
Five minutes.
Can't?
Gotta go?
We're hurting?
Fuck okay, two minutes.
I would reverse engineers
Queens, Base, Mets, there's
a lot of smart things that
could be done so I think
the answer is yes but
I don't think Adidas is
signing him to a Yeezy deal right?
So it's just being
realistic, finding interests,
and it's all about finding opportunities.
Finding startups that are
sitting with more money
than they know what to
do with and trying to
make a name for themselves in New York
and then compelling them to understand
that this is the guy.
And then it's finding the right partners.
We're producing content
for Postmates and things
of that nature, and AJ can
walk you through a little
bit more of that and I
know you gotta go too.
So keep putting pressure
on them to think about
it this way but the answer
is whether it's too early
or too not, you don't get unless you ask.
And honestly, you don't strike
me as man who needs to wait
or if that's appropriate
you don't need to wait
for your agent, you
just do your thing too.
- My agent wants to meet
with you so I said to set
something up, and I heard
that you are a card collector
so we bought you that one.
- That's what's up I appreciate it.
That's great, I appreciate that.
Can I have the case?
Hell yeah, I don't want
to bend this stuff.
Ultra-pro is still around?
Jesus Christ.
This is when I started my business.
Listen, we had a lot of
conversations about a lot of things,
I didn't take this meeting
just for kicks and giggles
I really wanted to meet and
say hello and say what's up
and see where the paths lead.
Feel free to reach out anytime,
and I will meet that guy.
Feel free to set that up,
and I wish you success.
- Thank you, appreciate it.
- My man.
Good luck to you.
- Thank you.
- Yeah, good luck, such a pleasure.
Hope you guys enjoyed it.
Fun fact, coffee in Australia
is just fuckin good.
I'll see you soon, leave
a comment, please leave
me a comment of your
favorite young athlete.
That's what I want to see
in the Youtube comments.
Let's make this a little
more interactive, a little
more fun, thank you so much
for watching the fuckin vlog.